I think of it as a mutual kind of idea that we all came up with and all love.
We're all kind of nerds, and people just made us giggle, so we went for it.
"Splat" is a game that allows up to 115 players to play at the same time on the same screen.
We basically wanted to make a game, something that was really interactive...
...that uses mobile devices to connect to it...
...that also worked with a large group or a large crowd.
Basically, when you walk up to the game, you log in using a mobile URL.
There's a button on your phone that says, "Poop", and all you do is just poop away.
Poop on all the targets below.
Poop on all the cars.
Poop on all, everything that goes by, to get points.
Eventually, we want to be able to do this in sporting arenas and huge conferences...
...and have tens of thousands of people potentially pooping in cars at the same time.
So far, we've only been able to show "Splat" just once to an audience.
So, we're extremely excited to be down at South By...
...and get a bunch of people playing the game...
...and giving us feedback and just having fun with it.
It's a dream, a dream come true.